Jeremy is with us in Tennessee hi Jeremy
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hey has
a gun better than I deserve what's up
well I have a delivery business and I
pay I rent the van I use for my dad and
I pay 800 a months for that but I can't
since I'm just paying it straight to my
dad I can't get a tax I can't get the
death did from attacks 100 a month yeah
it's a 15-passenger it's a ram 3500 okay
cool so your dad bought it over you to
use and he's had it for a while but once
this job came up I made a deal with and
then also the 800 also includes
insurance as well actually so my
question was would it be better if I
bought a van and lowered that payments
and I look into it and I could also get
if I bought it and I can also use that
in my tax I will never never make
business decisions for taxes make good
business decisions and then take the tax
write-off that it creates whatever that
is but don't go oh I did this because of
taxes that almost always indicates you
made a bad call because it means you
ignored other things that you should
have been looking at so you know we're
not doing this for taxes we're doing
this to I got to get rid of an $800
payment and I can get a $500 payment and
own it and and do the same job or a $400
payment or whatever how much money are
you making um and meet for the for taxes
and everything about fifty fifty
thousand a year so 48 hundred bucks a
month plus minus taxes - 800 - fuel and
repairs yeah
you're making 30 yes okay I'm not sure I
would go into that matter of fact I'm
positive I would not go into debt to own
a business that made thirty thousand
dollars a year and by the way doesn't
make a dime if you don't drive it and so
you don't really own a business you own
your job is all so um what's the van
cost my dad paid for it used at leafy
paid 7,000 for it $7,000 yeah you got he
got a good deal care why is it $800 a
month then because he likes the van and
he doesn't like putting miles on it and
all so you could buy the same van for
$7,000 I don't know if I could find one
like that
I'll bet you could right now okay
there's listen I mean like people are
freaking out and this is a great time to
buy stuff if you had money I don't
really want you going I mean I know I
don't want you going $30,000 in debt for
a $30,000 year job I'm not sure what
you're going in debt at all for a 30,000
or your job but if we could get you away
from an $800 payment it sounds like
you'd have a 100 or $200 payment yeah
yeah that's a move you want to make to
heck with the taxes that's a $600 swing
a month I mean we're talking an 80
percent swing in your in your
profitability here yeah yeah that that
likes his van way too much and so I'm
gonna let him have it back since he
likes it so much and I go get you
another one that's what I would do hey
thanks for the call man